let's say that we have the polynomial p
of x and when expressed in factored form
it is x plus 2
times 2x minus 3
times x minus 4. what we're going to do
in this video is use our knowledge of
the roots of this polynomial to think
about intervals where this polynomial
would be positive or negative and the
key realization is is that the sine of a
polynomial stays the same between
consecutive zeros let me just draw an
arbitrary
graph of a polynomial here to make you
appreciate why that is true so x-axis
y-axis and if i were to draw some
arbitrary polynomial
like that
you can see that between consecutive
zeros the sign is the same between this
zero and this zero the polynomial is
positive between this 0 and the 0 the
polynomial is negative
and that's almost intuitively true
because if it if the sign did not stay
the same that means you would have to
cross the x axis so you would have a 0
but we're saying between consecutive
zeros so between this zero and this zero
it is positive again then after that
zero it stays negative once again the
only way it wouldn't stay negative is if
there were another zero
so now let's go back to this example
here and let me delete this because this
is not the graph of p of x which i have
just written down let's first think
about its zeros so the zeros are the x
values that would either make x plus two
equals zero two x minus three equals
zero or x minus four equals zero
so first we can think about well what x
values would make x plus 2
x plus 2 equal to 0 well that of course
would be x equals negative 2.
what x values would make 2x minus 3
equals 0 2x minus 3 equal to zero add
three to both sides you get two x equals
three divide both sides by two you get x
equals three halves and then last but
not least what x values would make x
minus four
equal to zero add four to both sides you
get x is equal to four
and so if we were to plot this it would
look something like this
so this is
x equals negative two
x equals negative one
this is
zero
this is
one
two
three
and
four and let me draw the y axis here
so the y axis would look something like
this
x and y we have a zero at x equals
negative two
so our graph will intersect the x-axis
there
we have a zero at x is equal to three
halves which is one and a half which is
right over there and we have a zero at x
equals four which is right over there
and so we have several candidate
intervals and actually let me write this
down in a table
so the intervals
over which and this is really be between
consecutive consecutive zeros intervals
to consider
so i'll draw a little table here
so you have x is less than negative two
that's one interval
x is
less than actually let me color code
this
so if i were to say the interval for x
is less than negative 2
so that's this yellow that i'm i draw
the extreme left there we could have an
interval where
x is between negative 2 and 3 halves so
negative 2 is less than x is less than
positive 3 halves
that would be this interval
right over here
you have the interval i'm trying to use
all my colors
between three halves and four
this interval here so that would be
three halves is less than x is less than
four
and then last but not least you have the
interval where x is greater than 4
that interval right over there so x is
greater
greater than 4.
now all we there's a couple of ways of
thinking about whether over that
interval our function is positive or
negative one method is to just evaluate
our our p our function at a point in the
interval and if it's positive well that
means that that whole interval is
positive it's negative that means that
the whole interval is negative and once
again it's intuitive because if for
whatever reason it were to switch we
would have another zero i know i keep
saying that
but another way to think about it is
over that interval what is the behavior
of x plus 2 2x minus 3 and x minus 4
think about whether they're positive or
negative and use our knowledge of
multiplying positives and negatives
together to figure out whether we're
dealing with a positive or negative
so let's let's do it we can do it both
ways so let's think of this as our
sample x
sample
x value and then let's see what we can
intuit about or deduce about whether
over that interval we are positive or
negative
so for x is less than
negative two
maybe an easy one or an obvious one to
use it could be any value where x is
less than negative two but let's try x
is equal to
negative three
so you could try to evaluate p of
negative 3 you could just evaluate that
actually let's just do that so that's
going to be equal to negative 1
times
2 times negative 3 is negative 6 minus 3
is negative 9
negative 9 times negative 3 minus 4 that
is negative 7.
so if you were to multiply all of this
out this would give you negative 63
which is clearly negative
so over this interval right over here
our our polynomial is going to be
negative
so
then we can move on to the next one and
an interesting thing is we didn't have
to figure out the 63 part we can just
see that there's a negative times a
negative times a negative which is going
to be a negative and so let's just do
that going forward let's just think
about whether each of these are going to
be positive or negative and what would
happen when you multiply those positive
and negatives together
now in this second interval between
negative 2 and 3 halves what is going to
happen
well we could do a sample point let's
say x is let's say x is equal to 0. that
might be pretty straightforward
well when x is equal to 0 we're going to
be dealing with a positive
times a negative times a negative a
positive times a negative times a
negative and the reason why i did that
just in my head i said okay that's going
to be a positive 2
times a negative 3 times a negative 4.
so a positive times a negative times a
negative so i could write it this way
it's going to be a positive times a
negative
times a negative well a negative times a
negative is a positive and a positive
times a positive is a positive so we are
positive over that interval and if you
were to evaluate p of zero you will get
a positive value
now what about this next interval
what about this next interval here
between three halves and four
we could try x is equal to two
at when x is equal to two we are going
to get a positive
times a
positive
times a 2 minus 4 is negative times a
negative so this is going to be
negative over that interval and then
last but not least when x is greater
than 4 we could try x is equal to let's
say 5.
we are going to have a positive
positive times a
positive
times a positive
so
we are going to have a positive and as i
mentioned you could also do it without
the sample points you could say okay
when x is greater than 4 you can say
okay for any x greater than 4 if you add
2 to it that for sure is going to be
positive for any x greater than 4
if you multiply it by 2 and subtract 3
well that's still going to be
positive because 2 times something
greater than 4 is definitely greater
than 3 and for any x greater than 4 if
you subtract 4 from it you're still
going to have a positive value so that's
another way to think about it even if
you don't use a sample point
but there you have it we've figured out
the intervals over which the function is
negative or positive and we don't know
exactly what the function looks like but
generally speaking it's negative over
this first interval so it might look
something like this it's positive over
the net over that next interval
and then it's negative over that third
interval and then it's positive over
that last interval so it would have a
general shape like this we don't know
without trying out more points exactly
how high or low it would actually go